creo que todo el mundo puede elegir qué
tipo de sexo va a tener y eso puede ser
sagrado pero a veces solo quiero ser más
atrevido y hacer toda clase de cosas y
eso no es tan sagrado espectro
convocamos a 6 estrellas del porno para
medir los niveles de sus creencias y
valores
les pedimos que manifestaran su acuerdo
o desacuerdo con varias afirmaciones
sobre ser una estrella del porno el
porno es arte
el cine en sí mismo es arte pero el arte
también es subjetivo así que creo que mi
trabajo en cierto modo es un esfuerzo
creativo que puede ser considerado como
una forma de arte así es todo lo que
hacemos es un esfuerzo creativo yo firmo
muchas películas lo que significa que
ruedo mucho material que se firma como
las películas tradicionales es
básicamente lo mismo excepto que al
final nosotros tenemos sexo yo escogí
esta respuesta porque soy nueva en la
industria y no he hecho muchas películas
o grandes producciones todavía hago el
porno de realidad ya saben el chico de
la pizza que llama al timbre y tienes
sexo con una miel o algo así
así que en cierto modo no los veo como
arte bien pero el chico de la pizza se
coloca de cierta manera y te apoyo
tienen iluminación y cables alrededor
los menores deberían poder ver porno
el tipo de porno que los menores van a
conseguir probablemente sea el que está
libre en internet y hay muchas cosas que
esos vídeos omiten y que son importantes
no es muy educativo no les enseñan la
forma correcta de practicar el sexo el
consentimiento la lubricación estas
cosas son omitidas hay juegos de rol
fantasías y otras tantas cosas que
quisieras hacer pero que no puedes en la
vida real así que si en menor lo ve no
ve lo que ocurre entre bastidores en
donde los actores se comunican entre sí
y dicen puedes hacer esto pero de esta
manera ellos no ven eso en la pantalla
el porno es una fantasía no es una
realidad así que si un menor lo ve
tendrá una idea equivocada de lo que es
el sexo real y de cómo se hace cómo se
empieza y cómo se conoce a una chica la
caja está ahí y eso se llama cosas
sexuales si aprobáramos esto el sexo
sería mucho más insensible a temprana
edad y no queremos eso como sociedad
todavía queremos que el sexo sea algo
sagrado para los niños voy a decirlo
creo que la pornografía es una parte muy
importante del aprendizaje y un menor-
es alguien que tiene menos de 18 años
así que estamos hablando de 16 17
probablemente ya están viendo porno o
algo por el estilo claro que no es el
lugar donde se debería aprender sobre
sexo pero si lo están haciendo como
hacemos para que sea algo positivo
deben tener algo así como bueno sino
algo más educativo
el porno explota el racismo 3 2 1
aún no he rodado un interracial pase lo
que pase cuando lo haga van a colocarle
un título racista como todos son negros
negro con rubias pene negro en esta
pequeña chica blanca algo como eso y
recibo comentarios en instagram y en
twitter diciendo que soy racista y esas
cosas soy lo contrario totalmente quiero
hacer eso hay una página web ya saben
uno de los más grandes en nuestra
industria que es negro e interraciales
interracial es un tipo blanco con una
chica china internacional es casi
cualquier cosa así que considerar eso
solo al tipo oscuro con la chica blanca
creo que es tan estereotipado y ni
siquiera hacen eso se aseguran de que el
chico sea mucho más grande que la chica
para que parezca intimidante y
me pregunto por qué las personas no
habrían de sentirse intimidadas por la
cultura negra es complicado me he
encontrado productoras que me ofrecen
mucho dinero extra para grabar un
interracial y no ocurrido pero ya saben
cómo es esto una no deja de recibir toda
clase de comentarios diciendo o por
favor tienes que grabar con chicos
negros entonces necesitamos más bbc y
cosas así la gente quiere eso eso da
miedo y esto es lo aterrador de esta
conversación la gente realmente quiere
porno racista
mi familia aprueba lo que hago para
vivir 3 2 1
mi familia se enteró al día que salió mi
primera escena mi mamá me llamó y se
enfadó pero una semana después me dijo
te quiero y puedes venir a casa no todos
lo aprueban ellos quieren que vuelva a
la universidad pero me apoyan he tenido
una vida muy dura como hombre trans y ya
saben e intentado suicidarme y todo eso
así que mis padres están contentos de
que esté vivo y de que tengo éxito en el
negocio de la pornografía lo que hice
fue enseñar a mis padres que esto es un
negocio no se trata solo de porno sucio
y desagradable en realidad es un negocio
lucrativo si entiendes cómo crear un
negocio a partir de el parte de mi
familia sabe lo que hago y mis padres
dicen que lo aprueban dicen haz lo que
quieras eres adulta pero la otra parte
mis abuelos mis primos son mormones son
super religiosos me bloquearon en las
redes sociales ya no me invitan a las
reuniones familiares porque dicen puedes
hacer lo que quieras pero como nuestra
religión lo ve así no estamos cómodos
con que esté cerca de nuestros hijos y
cosas así
lo lamentable es que la gente como esa
se olvida de la persona que eres digo es
sólo un trabajo esto es solo un trabajo
para mí
es difícil para mí encontrar una
relación debido a mi trabajo 321
yo estoy casada somos abiertos y estamos
en una relación poli amorosa y creo que
uno puede conseguir lo que quiere y si
no te gusta lo que hago entonces no
hables conmigo muy bien mi mayor
problema es la monogamia porque si estás
conmigo debemos ser abiertos porque voy
a salir con otras personas es así estuve
casada un tiempo y terminamos porque él
quería ser monógamo y no podía soportar
verme saliendo con otras personas y
llega un punto en el que la gente se
pregunta bien queremos ser monógamos o
vamos a ser abiertos puedo soportar ser
abierto como ya saben estaba
comprometido con alguien de la industria
y
no es fácil encontrar a una persona con
la que tengas una conexión real en este
trabajo a veces el porn no puede
destruir las relaciones y puede destruir
a la gente porque
yo no la tengo
honestamente no sé
si alguna vez la tendré
porque a veces hay cosas que pueden
marcar te mentalmente no quería aceptar
lo que sucedía no quería pensar que
realmente la pornografía estaba
afectando mi relación dañando la ella
tanto como lo hacía a veces no hay nada
que puedas hacer y solo como yo digo
vives y aprendes
sucede muchas cosas que la gente no
entiende en el trabajo nos desconectamos
de la intimidad la gente no sabe cómo
hacer eso en su propia vida y creo que
por eso muchas veces no nos cree hay
gente que cree que es como el sexo
normal y les digo si yo me pongo así en
este ángulo por encima de esta chica
abrazándola y besándola este navegador
eso es lo que es solamente un trabajo
estamos desconectados y haces esto solo
como un movimiento y como un actor eres
un actor un actor
el sexo es sagrado 321
yo creo que sinceramente es una elección
muy personal todos deben tener la
oportunidad de elegir qué tipo de sexo
tendrá como quiere tenerlo cuando quiere
tenerlo porque quiere tenerlo si puede
ser sagrado en una situación en la que
tenga una pareja y quiera mantenerlo muy
personal y todo eso pero a veces solo
quiero ser más atrevido y hacer toda esa
clase de cosas y eso no es tan sagrado
hay relaciones sexuales en las que
sientes algo por la persona y luego está
el sexo genital en el que todo es más
primitivo hace unos años cuando yo
comencé en la industria con 18 años era
un desastre no sabía cómo separar mi
vida personal de mi vida de mi trabajo
no puedo ser aidenas yo y todo el tiempo
y cuando comencé aún no lo sabía pedía
un café y les decía que yo era hayden
entienden y así supe que tenía que
regresar y seguir teniendo mi verdadero
yo y luego convertirme en ied en cuando
voy a grabar
[Risas]
tienes un amigo es todo gracias quería
tener sus contactos
mi teléfono hola chicos mi nombre es
michael
muchas gracias por ver este episodio si
te gustó lo que viste suscríbete y
coméntanos que te ha parecido nos vemos